amazingly enough we're still on time
after one panel usually conferences like
wars go go awry soon as you have first
contact but we're actually on time I'm
will endeavor to stick to that so that
will require me to be at least as Stern
a sergeant major as Professor n bar was
so I'm Austin long I'll be training this
panel as well as speaking briefly at the
conclusion I'm an assistant professor
here at Columbia School of International
public affairs I'll really quickly
introduce the panelists in the order
they'll speak first Hallel frisch who's
associate professor at bar-ilan Hillel
is also a graduate of sepa as well as
doing his PhD at Hebrew University he
writes on a variety of Middle East
issues his most recent book is on the
Palestinian military next will be
professor gary sick who teaches here at
columbia as well where he's also a
senior researcher professor sick has a
long and storied career in the Middle
East as professor quant mentioned going
back to his time in the in the Navion on
the National Security Council under
presidents Ford Carter and Reagan he's
also written two books on Iran in the
United States relationship with Iran and
then finally professor n bar ephraim n
bar is the director of basa he's written
innumerable articles and several books
on Middle East security issues and his
experience goes back to his time as an
IDF paratrooper so I think we should
have a pretty wide array of viewpoints
on the panel ask the speakers to hold it
to 15 minutes or less it will not be
less I'm sure but nonetheless will allow
plenty of time for Q&A things it's
really a thrill to speak in a place
where you graduated from and I really
had a great time here and it was very
very intellectually rewarding I hope
that you'll feel that I'm providing the
fruits of that kind of education I'm
going to be speaking about on three
issues one is Egypt's prospects how does
that impact on the Gulf and what should
be done in terms of American of the
United States of national interests now
I think that it's very very important
just stress and focus on Egypt not to be
waylaid by Chirk by events in Libya
Egypt is the key to understanding how
events are going to unfold now we're
very early on in the process on
forecasting is a very difficult job as
an hour and commented on professional
revolutionaries usually when revolutions
break out it catches them unaware in the
coffee shops and we had a we had a
wonderful example of that there was the
immolation of this Tunisian man and a
for loan for Lorna tunisian town and not
set off and triggered this whole process
well we've had for t-mo at immolations
and attempted immolation since and none
have triggered the same effect so it's
very hard to forecast but we have at
least two bodies of literature in which
we could see get a sense of how events
in Egypt are going to play out one is
the literature on democratization on
Democratic transitions the second
literature is on revolutions basically
in democratization literature suggests
that the more top-down process wise the
larger the middle class structure larly
the more bloodless and successful the
transition to democracy Egypt does not
satisfy either of these two conditions
it wasn't a top-down process in the way
for instance that Taiwan or South Korea
were which were successful transitions
it was a revolution from below and the
middle class is not that large and that
in itself is disappointing news on to
fully Gorge successful or on or to
predict a successful transition and the
lessons from the revolution are even
more lugubrious
generally in revolutionary situations
it's the meanest the ugliest the
smallest and the most organized that
hijack revolutions and take over power
it was the Jacobins who produced the
guillotines in France that one out when
they were a minority against the
Royalists and the Liberals it was the
Bolsheviks who took over from the
mensheviks the Social Democrats and in
probably the most pertinent example for
Egypt the Iranian Revolution it was
exactly the same thing the revolution
began as a middle-class protests in
liberal Iranian universities and they
were hijacked by the Islamic militants
in fact we should remember and recall
the fate of peshawar bakhtiyar the first
prime minister after the fall of the
Shah this man was a professor of
political science his french was better
than his Farsi he had side burns which
worst I which were in style at the time
well he was used and abused and then
discarded and then in 1991 was murdered
by the Islamists in his French exile and
if that's not enough let us reflect on
MIDI valzer by bizarre gan Bazargan who
was an Islamic scholar he wasn't
murdered but was totally marginalized
and we've been living with the effects
of that revolution ever since when I was
reading the New York Times I on the G on
Egypt I kept on reflecting on how little
the New York Times has learned since the
last round of promise in in Iraq now why
should I think
that this that it's the Iranian
precedent that will that fully reflects
development potential developments in
the Egypt well let me give you a couple
of indications why I think that this is
how that it's the Iranian way that will
play out if we look at the 2005
elections in Egypt which was the last
seven free elections how many Muslim
Brotherhood members wanted will secured
seats in the Egyptian in the Egyptian
parliament 88 all the up for opposition
parties the other four opposition
parties garnered seven seats a ratio of
11 to 1 in other words they're not only
the meanest the ugliest the most
organized but they numerically
significant as well now there was an
article by Scott at Ron in the New York
Times where he claimed no the Muslim
Brotherhood is not that strong maybe
only twenty to twenty-five percent of
the Egyptian electorate support them but
it's not the absolute power that you
wield in revolutionary situations it's
the balance of power now what happens in
the leg there'll be enough free
elections out there in a year's time
what happens in the first elections
after the downfall of regimes even in
the most successful cases so i looked at
poland and I looked at hungry do you
know how many parties contested the
Polish elections in nineteen ninety
seventy five parties I repeat 75 parties
in hungry 50 parties now when you think
of an Egyptian voter after a year of
instability and every day in Egypt I'm
not being waylaid by Libya I keep on
reading alarm and the postings and
dialect our Egyptian and in Arabic and
every day there
is a major crisis of instability strikes
by organized by organized groups the
burning of police stations by former
undercover detectives I the burning of
churches sectarian crisis every day
every day in and out this feeling of
instability is increasing now the
average Egyptian voter is come going to
come to the voting booth in a year's
time and he's going to be tired of that
instability and he's going to see a
roster of parties the Muslim Brotherhood
which he knows since 1928 and 50 other
parties and he's dying for stability he
or she who is he or she going to vote
for they're going to vote for the Muslim
Brotherhood not out of love but out of
hope that maybe the Muslim Brotherhood
will give them stability it's even worse
than that the Muslim Brotherhood as a
has a fantastic strategy they announced
that they won't be part of any
government until the elections why is
this brilliant well because expectations
during revolutionary situations increase
at but capabilities d trees every
successive government including the
military their luster dims and I want to
tell you in the postings to lr vom they
keep on talking about where is the
military where is the military why
aren't they defending these police
stations and all and and and um
preventing massacres of a village as
which one took place in two weeks two
weeks ago when criminals descended on a
village and killed 23 people they were
trying they decided to try defendant
themselves and they were and they were
and they were slaughtered meanwhile as
the
Buster of all these government's
technocrats and luminaries that might
join the government dims by the time
elections take place there will be only
one group whose luster still remains
intact that's going to be the Muslim
Brotherhood now why I get to the second
part of my speech why is Egypt so
important i'm going to give you an
argument that Egypt is the major Arab
Sunni state and that basically the Arabs
finally reentered history after eight
hundred years of losing history to the
church to turkic-speaking and farsi
people it's not known but they ruled
over most of the Arabs since the fall of
the Abbasid Empire and even way before
that in the 13th century have been ruled
by non Arabs it was Jamal Abdullah civ
who brought back in a very problematic
way the Arabs into history well now with
the potential disintegration of Egypt
the Arabs might be receding once again
from history before the sentence of the
two kinds of peoples who ruled over them
for 800 years the Iranians and the
church now this will increase the
propensity the propensity of the Gulf
states to what's called in I our Theory
bandwagoning with the Iranians what is
bandwagoning it's exactly what Kings was
saying did in 1967 with jamel Abdel
Nasser jamel of the Nassif tried on
frequent occasions to kill King Hussein
but when push came to shove in May 1967
king hussein wisely decided that it no
wise leader
did that it was better half a kingdom
than no Kingdom and all they knew that
them Israelis would overrun Judea and
Samaria the West Bank within two days
but they they felt that if they wouldn't
bandwagon with jamal abdul nasir they
will be left without a West Bank and an
east bank Hungary Romania during the
Second World War did the same thing the
full or the potential disintegration of
the strongest Arab Sunni state will have
a dramatic resonance on these states
that could be called walk over States
because all these states could be walked
over the Gulf states by any by any
potential by any real real military
really real military power now what why
why is bandwagoning of Gulf states the
potential such such a problem and I
argue it's a problem because Egypt if it
comes under the sway of the Muslim
Brotherhood there's no way that Iran
alone can refinance or can finance the
remilitarization of Egypt but the Gulf
states under pressure of Iran could
possibly bring this about and this would
completely change that the power balance
in the Middle East there's no way even
the United States could live with a
remilitarization is all about we'll find
it hard to deal with the states that my
tree militarize with Gulf state
financing and of course there's the oil
the oil problem which the Gulf states
which the on which any kind of
bandwagoning of the Gulf states with
Iran will be very um threat
so what has to be done and that's my
third and final comments the first thing
is that Europe and the United States
should as much try to politically
organized those inevitably fragmented
liberals or westernized groups so at
least if we don't have 50 at least we'll
have ten parties and then to try to form
coalition's and the gap the the
divisions are deep the divisions between
the Coptic liberals and the Muslim
liberals is really really deep the
division divisions between the true
capitalist business business people and
the business people who who were cronies
to Mubarak are very very very deep there
are many many divisions but at least try
to organize them the United States and
the European community should try
already anticipating Democratic
subversion when the Muslim Brotherhood
takes over trying to block teach teach
activists how to block state attempts at
curtailing Facebook and other
interactive modes which empower our
positions against autocratic states and
I think I think that it would be
advisable to prevent to prevent
bandwagoning for a more assertive United
States sometimes we forget that the
United States in 2004 achieved
militarily uh something that is
comparable to the German blitzkrieg
blitzkrieg the 1967 war it took over
Iraq in three weeks the United States
has military power it can use it
effectively to show who's the boss and
it doesn't have to do it with troops on
the ground I think that that's an
important lesson I think the Americas
should wait in the anticipation that
maybe demonstrations will pass will
reach Iran I think the Libyan precedent
of intervention which is terrible for
American interest in Libya because it
can only get worse in Libya but it was a
good precedent in the sense that it
legitimized intervention which leaves a
better more even playing field between a
potential civilian opposition and the
state it should give a time but after
some time if that doesn't break out it's
the demonstrations don't break out I
think America the Americans should use
massive force negotiations through
bombings and show the middle the middle
east states who are on societies or in
state or in a state of tremendous flux
who is the boss thank you very much
sometimes the the conventional wisdom is
correct and in this case when people are
talking about the current crisis in the
Middle East I think it deserves that
name I think this really is the most
extraordinary series of events that
certainly has happened in my lifetime I
was thinking back about where you can
find a comparison with this one that
really comes to mind actually as the
1967 war which transformed the Middle
East in all kinds of ways and one of the
things that happen if you look at the
fact that the 1967 Israel succeeded in a
few days accomplishing what the Arabs
had thought they had built up in the way
of Defense the herbs were humiliated the
Arabs in return turned first of all to
Islam as the solution to all their
problems and secondly a lot of changes
took place and so you had a whole new
set of rulers that came in on the tales
of 1967 war because of the humiliation
of their predecessors and we're still
living those are the people that are
getting kicked out right now basically
the people who came in there that was a
real shift that really transformed the
Middle East in an interesting way an
earlier example which I'm not going to
go into could be 1916 when the Arab
world was actually carved up and divided
but I think you have to look at events
like that to find predecessors for what
is going on today which is absolutely
astonishing I wrote a an article called
the coming crisis in the Persian Gulf
which unfortunately I don't take great
pride in first of all because I wrote it
in 1997 and following that 14 years went
by and nothing happened at all and then
when it did begin to happen it didn't
happen the way I thought it would
all so I I don't but I would offer that
at least the title of that as a as an
indicator of the fact that a lot of
people knew that there were big problems
this was not a secret there were lots
and lots of problems existing in the
Arab world and elsewhere that were the
basis for this kind of a change in fact
everybody knew that if that these
Emperor's had no clothes that was not a
secret at all because of the way they
advantage the economy because the
stultifying foreign policy programs that
they pursued their inability to get
anything done the lack of credibility
that they had the mismanagement of all
of their economies unemployment it just
goes on and on and on and everybody knew
that what we didn't know was when and
how that process would begin to change
and I think we've now seen that and that
in itself what and of course it was not
the it was not Facebook and Twitter and
others that made this happen it was the
underlying conditions that existed there
at the time and I would remind you that
in the Iranian Revolution which also
moved pretty swiftly they used cassette
tapes and you had Khomeini sitting off
in Paris making periodic statements
those would be telephoned to Iran where
they would be mass produced and
reproduced and then handed out in the
bazaar that we would regard that as an
awfully slow and cumbersome way to get
your point across it worked and in the
you know in the Soviet Union they used
samizdat you know mihnea graphing papers
in little books or big books and then
covertly passing them around to each
other communications is important and
you can do it a variety of ways but this
was unusual in the fact that it was
really fast and so you could have this
exchange of you
people talking about what was going on
elsewhere in a matter of seconds whereas
in the past it took a lot longer than
that and I do think that that had the
effect the social networking had a real
effect in terms of speeding things up up
the I think one has to ask you know why
did these rulers fall so quickly in many
cases I think it was because after 30 or
40 years in power they had worked out
their little bag of tricks they knew
what worked and they knew that if there
was a challenge they would just pull out
their bag of tricks and that would take
care of it all of a sudden they
discovered that the tricks didn't work
that people were no longer as afraid as
they used to be and that they were
forced to shift and I think they lost
their nerve in many cases and then in
those few cases where we see them not
not losing their nerve and standing and
being prepared to kill their own people
other things happen that intervene and
I'm going to talk a little bit about
that there's a sort of in fact we've
seen examples of here in our discussions
today there's a sort of ruling
assumption that the only thing that can
happen in the Middle East is when
somebody from the outside makes it
happen that external intervention is
absolutely essential and to me the real
lesson of what we have seen in this Arab
with some people covering the great Arab
Awakening or the Arab Spring or what
have you is it was domestic these were
not driven by outside forces and I yell
you can draw various conclusions from
this but what was not on the placards
that were being held up in Tahrir Square
they weren't saying Islam is the
solution that was not part of the that
was not part of the deal they were
nonviolent the only violence was coming
from their leaders was coming from the
regime's and that was where it came from
there was no mention of Israel there was
no mention of the United States
basically these people had their own
agendas
they knew what they were about they went
they went after it that doesn't mean
that they will get it and it is
absolutely true that revolutions tend to
go awry along the way and I think we
have to be prepared for that that the
Arab Spring will turn into an air of
winter I think this is something that we
need to think about but we have now had
two interventions one in Libya where the
battle is going on currently the other
one was in Bahrain where Saudi Arabia
sent troops across the causeway along
with some other GCC states to intervene
in what was going on in baja rain
because they were worried that the
Bahraini government was going to lose
its nerve and give in to some of the
required some of the objectives of the
people who were working against them in
effect the Gulf Cooperation Council has
sort of transformed itself into a
monarchical Protection Society and
basically saying that if you are a
monarch ruling in the GCC this little
Club of rulers in the Gulf if things
start to go bad we will come in and see
to it that nothing changes and that it
stays about the way it was I think it
would be a mistake however both in Iran
and in Egypt and Libya and all of the
other countries that are going on to
sort of come out of this with the
conclusion that somehow it's only Iran
that was at stake in this thing I do
think that the Saudi intervention was
conducted on the grounds that there was
a sectarian divide and the Saudis were
terribly afraid of Shia getting some
kind of control of what was going on and
they have in fact really turned this
into a sectarian conflict in in Bahrain
at the beginning baha rain had Sunni and
Shiah together marching side-by-side
with many of the same requirement with
some of the same requests that is no
longer true they
the Sunnis now have been intimidated
they're staying home and this is all
being perceived through what i think is
an incorrect lens of sectarianism from
saudi arabia it is no question that the
Saudis themselves are terrified of Iran
and they're terrified of Shia influence
let me just digress for a one second to
think about where this terrible
influence of Iran came from if you will
recall in 2001 the United States
intervened in Afghanistan and did away
with Iran's worst enemy to the east the
Taliban then before that job was done we
turned around and intervened in Iraq
where we got rid of Iran's worst enemy
to the west which happened to be Saddam
Hussein then we presided over the
installation of a Shia government in
Baghdad for the first time in many
centuries and for all of that the
Iranians didn't lift a finger they
didn't do a thing but at the end of the
day they were in fact left in a position
of greater influence in the Gulf and
Middle East then they had been for
within living memory I've had Iranian
friends say you know I'm not quite sure
why you did this but we thank you very
much it was very kind of you I had a I
had a discussion one time with a senior
American policy official who was
involved in that process and he was
railing on about all the terrible things
that Iran was doing and I said yeah I
agree with you it doesn't look all that
great but I said didn't we have
something to do with that and he stopped
for a second and he said well we didn't
mean to
frankly I don't think the Arabs by that
that this all happened in a fit of
absent-mindedness they remember our
relations with the Shah they remember
the iran-contra affair where the United
States covertly was trying to open up to
Iran and sell arms together with Israel
and those two together they look at this
and they say oh you say you just didn't
notice that you were doing all of these
things I don't think they believe it and
I think the next opportunity that comes
along they're going to see it as part of
a American plot let me finish up simply
because we haven't really talked about
American foreign policy in the Gulf and
American foreign policy generally I
think it is very hard to make any
predictions about where things are going
to go I don't think we know I think
we're going to be surprised but I do
believe that we're going to have a
different world to deal with and I all
of the old assumptions which a lot of
arm policies in the Middle East were
based on things like the fact that you
could rely on Egypt to take care of the
southern border of Gaza those are not
necessarily going to remain true
especially if these countries turn into
more democratic states where the voice
of the people actually gets heard it's
going to be harder and harder to
maintain that I also think that it's a
mistake to think that Iran is going to
be the beneficiary of all of this that
it's a zero-sum game and that they're
going to come out of it on top actually
a lot of the press and support that
ahmadi nejad for instance has received
over the years has been because he was
willing to say things mostly about
Israel that the other that the Arab
leaders couldn't say or wouldn't say in
public and people thought that was just
dandy I mean that was really nifty and
they liked it now if there's going to be
governments in place where the voice
the people get some resonance I think
Iran is going to suffer from that as
much as anybody else that their their
message is not going to be unique what
do I think is required i think it's not
what's required i think what's going to
happen is that the United States is
going to wind down its wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan over a relatively short
period of time people are losing
interest in those in a major way and are
turning away from it and I think there's
going to be and there needs to be a sort
of zero based foreign policy analysis
based on the new realities in the region
and starting without preconceptions and
starting without the working assumptions
that we've worked with and looking at it
with clear eyes without in fact wishful
thinking and if that means that the
United States is going to have a smaller
footprint in the Persian Gulf 10 years
from now than it does today I think it's
going to I think that's going to happen
if you see that as the end of American
influence in the world i think you're
wrong i think that that is the world is
changing and the united states is going
to have to change with it if we don't
understand that our policy in the region
is doomed to really greater disasters
than we've had to this point I'm going
to stop at that point and I'm seeing
there'll be some questions
good day and I'll speak about a nuclear
Iran a I'll speak about a nuclear Iran
the pleasant turmoil in the Middle East
and I'm not sure it's going to bring
about a revolutionary effect but this is
a different issue however what we see
today it deflects much attention
probably from the most important issue
in the Middle East and this is the
Iranian quest for a nuclear weapon most
of the world understands that this
combination of a radical Islamist regime
with nuclear weapons is not such a great
idea there are many reasons and I'm not
going to elaborate why a nuclear Iran is
bad news for the region and for the west
and if I try to look what is America
doing what is always doing I am quite
disappointed because what we see today
is economic sanctions which are somewhat
less vegetarians and the well maybe a
year ago they definitely have some
effect on the Iranian economy but even
if they hurt even more they will not
stop the nuclear quest because do not
delude yourself the regime is determined
to get the bomb the bomb is an insurance
policy for the regime they understand
very well that if they get a bomb will
be much in a stir in a much stronger
position to exist for an influence for
an intervention just like North Korea or
Pakistan it's a high
of the bush who said for democracy in
the Middle East Pakistan was spared why
because it's a nuclear weapon and if
it's destabilized because of democracy
or democratization they are bad guys are
they can put the hands on the bomb and
believe me in in Iran they are even
crazier guys enough Ahmed injured what
do we do serve some delaying tactics
sabotage the program we have Stuxnet
removal of scientists which is important
because we gain some time no little
measures are always preferable but we
should not underestimate the ability of
the Iranian engineers to fix the
problems and to eventually to get the
bomb if they will be unintended a
strategy which was not really tried is
regime change so we'll half-hearted
effort which obviously were not
successful this approach has several
weaknesses first of all the ability of
outsiders to influence domestic event is
very limited and i agree with a remark
made by professor see apart from that if
we take a look at the opposition in iran
that is demonstrating those are not the
nice guys so I'm a different version of
the Islamists third and this is
something which we do not always realize
suppression repression works in the
Middle East so therefore don't hold your
breath if we see demonstrations in the
streets of Tehran this is why probably
will not see change in Syria in Bahrain
oublie in Egypt because those regimes
have a great steak in staying in power
we don't have too many retired
presidents in the Middle East
it's a job for life having a state is a
good business and the alternative is not
always exile the alternative is to be
slaughtered in the streets by the people
you tortured a few years ago the West
actually signals weakness particularly
President Obama engagement in the Middle
East engagement of the enemy's Syria
Iran is seen as appeasement in the
Middle East you don't engage your
enemies you weaken them you kill them
you don't engage them Iranians are
simply not afraid and allow me to
disturb some of your liberal
sensitivities feel is the best political
currency in the Middle East much of the
talk in Washington today is about
containment we are told by government
officials and some irresponsible
academics that Iran even a nuclear Iran
can be contained to be Rima to remind
you the u.s. in February 94 announced by
Martin in dixon dual containment what
are the results of American containment
of Iran did the u.s. stop progress in
the Iranian nuclear program no did the
US stop Iran for meddling in Afghanistan
Iraq no did the u.s. prevent the
build-up of Hezbollah an Iranian poxy in
Lebanon no did us contain Iran influence
in Gaza hold Hamas the answer is again
no did the US contains the rise of the
Iran in the Middle East no did the US
contains the influence of Iran in
Venezuela in your backyard no I'm not
sure what
usage of containment is is English
language here in America maybe it's
appeasement the Soviet Union was
contained in several arenas because
there was a clear American commitment to
respond militarily containment without
the readiness to use military force does
not work the only time when Iran stopped
for a while the nuclear program
weaponization was when America invaded
Iraq in 2003 if the u.s. is not ready to
flex its muscles be it a naval blockade
or a military strike Iran will remain
unimpressed so will be the rest of the
Middle East actually only use of force
can give containment a chance another
strategic delusion in western capitals
is that Iran can be easily deterred
actually we cannot easily emulate in the
Middle East the american-soviet delicate
balance of terror as it was put quite
nicely by professor albert was already
in 1957 we are talking about rationality
I believe that the Iranians are rational
but still Ahmadinejad talks to the
Hidden Imam we don't know what he is he
has some epiphany this is the type of
rational people we are ready to deal in
a nuclear situation also deterrence
depends primarily upon sensitivity to
cost and we know quite well that the
Iranians are ready to pay a high price
for getting their goals
furthermore in nuclear deterrence what
works is effective second strike states
are not born with second strike
capabilities it takes time to develop
them in the meantime there is a great
pressure to preempt the command and
communication systems in the Middle East
are very weak the distances are very
small a multipolar nuclear Middle East
is a strategic nightmare actually only
military action unfortunately can stop
Iran from acquiring a nuclear bomb and
strengthening its regime only Western
military action can reverse the trend of
Iranian ascendance in the Middle East
and restore Western influence I know you
want to get out of Iraq you want to get
out of Afghanistan probably the only way
to get out convincingly without being
seen as a dog with his tail between its
legs is to leave those countries was a
big bang in Iran thank
tough act to follow I'd like to talk
about Iraq and Iran particularly the
nuclear program in Iran professor n bar
set me up very well for that but I'd
like to take a little bit of time to
talk about Iraq and the the punch line
for Iraq is that both in terms of us
domestic politics and executive focus we
are unprepared for the future of Iraq we
the United States even before the recent
events in the Middle East attention to
shifted Afghanistan Pakistan Yemen a
variety of other places that that
acceleration is only has only picked up
speed but at the same time Iraq has
hasn't gone away I mean I would make an
analogy to whack Amole where the United
States hits one problem and another pops
up but it's actually worse than that
because the moles won't actually stay
whacked and Iraq is not a solved problem
it's a it's a problem it's stabilized
but it's not it's not it's not done and
I'd like to highlight a few reasons why
I think absent continued US involvement
on a pre robust scale after the end of
this year Iraq could go south quite
quickly first is the military weakness
of Iraq it actually looks pretty robust
compared to where it was say in 2005 but
it's quite weak one example Iraq does
not have an air force capable of
controlling its own air space it will
not by the end of this year if you talk
to senior Iraqi military leaders this
presents them with a little bit of a
dilemma in the sense that if the u.s.
really does withdraw they will not be
able to control their own airspace so
the idea that the United States can can
just split at the end of the year at
least with all uniformed personnel will
leave Iraq without without the ability
to control its own airspace which you
can think of a variety of situations
where that might be problematic on a
deeper level there's an ongoing weakness
with one of the most capable forces
interact the Iraqi Special Operations
Forces these are focused on
counterterrorism they target al-qaeda in
Iraq and other
enemies in the Iraqi state but they have
two principal weaknesses one they don't
have legal basis these were essentially
created by the United States and taken
over by Prime Minister Maliki there are
without legal basis they're run out of
out of his slush fund essentially should
should there be political change in Iraq
you're looking at a situation where this
very capable force could rapidly become
d legitimate on top of that many Iraqis
particularly Sunnis but not exclusively
Sunnis see a rockin special operations
forces as Prime Minister Maliki's leg
breakers so they lack both a legal
standing and popular legitimacy so
political change of any meaningful sense
in Iraq could deprive the United States
of its strongest sort of action arm
inside Iraq and also d legitimate
continued US Special Operations activity
in Iraq which by the way will continue
after the end of this year it's quite
quietly so that's one potential serious
problem another is the problem of the
supplies the United States is giving to
Iraq the rock is buying some pretty
sophisticated US military hardware
particularly the m1 tank it's quite a
nice tank but in words of one u.s.
logistician without support it becomes
the world's most expensive and heaviest
paperweight and unfortunately Iraq is
not going to be up to the logistics
challenge in terms of maintaining that
so without US troops they'll have to
look for some other solution one
solution that's proposed is contractors
have US contractors come in do the
maintenance etc the problem with that
and it works in other countries the
problem with that for Iraq is Iraq is
not Saudi Arabia it's not nearly as
stable the Saudi is and of course as
we've seen even apparently stable
regimes can go south quite quickly so
it's going to be I think unusually
challenging to find contractors at
general dynamics or wherever who want to
base themselves on a permanent basis in
Iraq in order to maintain Iraq's nice
shiny new fleet of m1 tanks without that
as I said this is this is going to be
a logistical nightmare so a lot of the
stuff that we're selling to Iraq that's
above the level of small arms maybe
potentially useless without ongoing US
involvement there's also the question of
politicization in the military and
intelligence services in Iraq in the
military many division level commanders
and probably devote below division level
commanders are associated with one
political party or another several are
associated with the two main Kurdish
parties some are associated with Sunni
parties in Anbar some are associated
with different Xie parties but the point
is there's a strong element of
politicization this is not terribly
surprising given how politicized
Saddam's military was but between that
and overall corruption military
effectiveness and the potential for
fragmentation of the military can't be
understated so there's the potential if
there's a some major conflict either on
the borders or inside Iraq that you
could see the military begin to fragment
the intelligence services in Iraq aren't
any better you have the Iraqi National
Intelligence Service which was built up
by the Central Intelligence Agency in
order to compete with that explicitly
there's been the creation of the
Ministry of State for national security
affairs which is seen as a counterweight
to to the allegedly alleged CIA
influence I NIS and there's the
potential for that kind of covert
rivalry to continue as well so this is
not only the potential for fragmentation
but also limits intelligence collection
and intelligence sharing the United
States has been able to mitigate some of
these shortfalls and intelligence and
has been able to provide some level of
oversight and ensure some level of
sharing in the Iraqi intelligence
community without continued US
involvement on a pre-major scale I think
this is just going to get worse and
finally have the question of the Sons of
Iraq who were former insurgents and
tribesmen who signed up for a
paramilitary program additionally under
the United States later taking over
iraqis state at their peak there were
about a hundred thousand of these
principally but not exclusively Sunni
fighters in Baghdad there were about
fifty thousand many of them had been
transitioned but at least thirty to
forty thousand in other parts of Iraq
have not there's an ongoing question of
what's going to happen to them there's a
potential they could return to violence
at least if you believe newspaper many
are filtering back into al Qaeda in Iraq
and other terrorist organizations so I
think you know anybody that follows the
the very back pages of the newspapers
these days will see that there's still a
steady drumbeat of violence in Iraq the
political situation is not resolved
itself and the United States is by and
large going to have to retain a role
there we're just simply unprepared for
this there is no publicly stated plan
though if you listen to beltway gossip
there's probably a plan somewhere in the
bowels of the Pentagon or down in Tampa
at CENTCOM to maintain a US presence
after 2011 but as Professor quant
professor sick of both pointed out
there's not really a domestic consensus
in the United States to do that I think
one can be built in part because the
body count will be quite low for such a
mission it's already dropped off to
almost nothing it can be that can
continue with that level but absent an
effort and a focus by the executive
branch in particular to build that
consensus I think the United States
really could be out of Iraq within the
2011 or fairly disastrous consequences
I'll talk briefly about Iran I agree
with many of the points that Professor
and barmaid covert action has made a lot
of progress but as we saw with the Iraqi
case at o serac 1970s and early 1980s it
will buy a fairly limited delay but it
will not stop them so that leaves some
crummy options as he points out
deterrence is never certain it rests on
both the secure second strike and
willingness to dialogue in crisis and he
concludes that military action is a
necessity I think military action can be
remarkably successful in the short to
medium term we can talk about that in
na i don't i don't believe the stories
that there are vast legions of hidden
iraqi scientist working in a vast
underground complex that's unobservable
and therefore you will get minimal
effect from military action military
action can buy you delay of some years
maybe even five years but it can't end
the program we saw that with with o
serac it bought a ten year delay but it
did not in iraq's nuclear ambitions and
they had come quite far in the
intervening decade so some people argue
maybe you just have to mow the lawn so
to speak every 53 10 however many years
you launch another strike on Iranian
nuclear facilities and maybe they buried
them a little deeper each time maybe
they hide them a little better but you
can find them you can hit them in
particularly if the u.s. does it the
United States has has vast air assets
that have their limitations but for
blowing up fixed targets are quite
robust the problem with this is if you
fail at mowing the lawn you may have
actually made the deterrence problem
much worse and I'd say this because Iran
will be incentivized not to have what
some people call a recessed Arsenal
which Israel is alleged to have at this
time that is to say an Arsenal that's
not fully assembled ready to go at a
moment's notice instead Iran having been
pretty substantially poked in the eye on
their program before will want to deploy
I think this will put a lot of pressure
on Israel to sort of come out of the
closet and deploy an arsenal as well and
as Professor n bar points out neither
one of these will be a terribly secure
second strike Israel could probably be a
lot further along than Iran but the
point is there will be a premium on
preemption on both sides and its various
Israeli activities have shown there's
already a bit of a proclivity to preempt
in the Israeli military strategic
culture so in a crisis that emerges in a
post military strike crisis but between
Iran and Israel you have the potential
for actually driving up the preemption
on both sides because Iran will know its
arsenal it's vulnerable and if you know
your arsenal is vulnerable you have a
real use or lose incentive so what I
think military actually be very
effective in shorts medium-term it runs
the risk of
can the long-term problem much less
tractable Thanks alright we have we have
a microphone and please come up and
we'll do questions one at a time just
because I'm a bit dopey and lose track
Ronald Hellman so uh three points first
one of the coins of the political
science realm in modern times the
democracies don't go to war against
democracies looking at the empirical
evidence it's a fairly strong case so my
first question is if that is a valid
hypothesis would that not be a very
compelling reason for Israel to look to
the changes that are dramatic changes
that are taking place now in their
neighborhood as in the end beneficial
because it would in a sense validate or
not validate that political science
hypothesis second question is do with
the footprint that Professor sick had
raised about possibly reducing the
footprint but it seems to me that the
President Obama is trying to deal with
what maybe one could call some
collateral repair as opposed to
collateral damage in the international
system by stressing cooperation
multilateralism negotiations etc etc so
i was wondering to what extent that
initiative bears on the size of the
footprint that we are going to witness
from now and into the future and my
third is more of a comment more than a
question has to do with some quaint
old-fashioned ideas in foreign policy in
the United States things like
multi-party bipartisan ISM
non-intervention
self-determination all of those kinds of
things what where do we stand with
regard to the the need what not to have
the need to kind of reconstruct the
sense of a bipartisan foreign policy in
this country and as well as the role
that our friends and partners in the
rest of the world in particularly in the
Middle East play that we move in that
direction rather than we move in a
perpetually increasing partisan eyes
policy stance internationally so those
are the three issues democracy
internationalism and partisan ism
sure can can we get AV can we get the
volume turned up on the mic so
well that that that that that like is
much so yeah make make sure that Mike's
on go ahead Gary do you want to respond
we got three on the table let's let's
answer those then we'll get to the net
will democracy help Israel in the Middle
East I think we don't know but I know
since I think something like that is
probably coming maybe Israel would be
well advised to try to make the best of
it rather than saying any kind of change
in the leadership or the authoritarian
traditions of these countries any change
in that is going to be bad for Israel
I'm not sure that's true I'm not sure
it's going to be a pollyannaish and
simply say that if there's more freedom
of expression in Egypt or some other
country that that necessarily is going
to work to Israel's benefit I think it's
likely to work to Israel's benefit in
the long run I think there's going to be
a lot of objection in the short run
because a lot of the old assumptions and
this is what I was talking about
basically that we have a bunch of
assumptions that we have just become
very accustomed to of what kinds of
things we can expect from Egypt or other
countries and probably those are going
to change and you know if we say oh they
can't possibly we can't let them change
I think talk about being on the wrong
side of history you really are going to
be on the wrong side of history and I
think that fits the United States as
well as it does Israel that basically
and this goes to the second point about
the internationalism and the like the
United States you know we can talk all
we like about United States has to throw
its weight around and show them who's
boss and be tough and be prepared to
intervene well tell the american people
then
you know it's maybe it suits the
strategic interests of a number of
parties both in this country and in
other countries in the Middle East but
that doesn't make it doesn't make it
happen and I think the reality is that
any kind of internationalist approach or
balancing of power instead of the u.s.
coming and doing it all that a balance
of power is probably going to emerge
whether we like it or not that's going
to be an efficient effective way of
taking care of your business and how
that fit is in terms of a bipartisan
foreign policy I don't know except that
right now if you really wanted to divide
the American electorate even more than
it has been try going to war with
another country and then at least about
the Democratic peace well one of the
Columbia University's most influential
professors points out Jack Snyder points
out that new democracies it's that if
what will emerge will be democratic um
tend to make war more than peace in
other words the Democratic peace is true
of very mature democracies let's not
forget the First World War maybe the
worst war ever was between at least
nominally democratic states so this is
the argument made by a prominent
political scientist who works in this in
this in this building we also tend to
forget how long revolutionary situations
play out I mean usually it takes at
least 10 years before things get better
even in the most successful
revolutionary situations Poland and
Hungary achieved economic levels
socio-economic levels of the last years
of communism
to 10 years of massive infusions of aid
from the European Community and the
United States a type of envelopment that
that the Arab that the states in the
Middle East will never get I'm third
point about the Democratic peace is that
freedom house now is pointing out to a
regression in in democratization the
world over in the last 45 years becoming
Democratic is a very very difficult
business usually revolutionary
situations yield lost generations
terrible terrible experiences it usually
begins with the meanest taking over then
civil war and then foreign intervention
or international war we can't allow our
hearts to overcome our minds now
regarding internationalism offshore
balancing you know every time in other
in the eye our community mere sham wall
timer and I'm Walt a mere timer and Walt
you know they always say instead of an
offensive American posture we should do
offshore balancing offshore balancing
with boo Iran is now being more and more
supported by the second powerhouse
Turkey which is becoming more and more
anti-western more I mean in many ways
maybe anti-democratic on that that that
leaves that that leaves on that's very
problematic and the American public
finally regarding though I know very
little about American politics but being
being successful being strong is good
for American business as well and it's
an American interest on bipartisanship
I'll just say that I've been struck by
how much continuity there's been between
some aspects of Bush foreign policy and
Obama's foreign policy and pretty
remarkable
coherence I mean if anything
particularly on counterterrorism stuff
Obama has has turned it up from where
Bush was and with the support of a
Republican Congress I mean there are
very few things you can get the
Republicans and Democrats to to agree on
but some aspects particularly the more
shall we say muscular aspects of u.s.
foreign policy there's been agreement
now I think that may that may peter out
when it comes as Gary says to starting
another war but a lot of ways there
there is remarkable bipartisan foreign
policy consensus it tends to be more
center right than to the left please job
lady given its current drift what sort
of problems could turkey pose for US
policy going forward and is it
conceivable that turkeys membership in
NATO would ever become untenable will
they go it's my understanding i know i
read this a while back that either it's
been developed or is on the verge of
being developed the largest
bunker-busting bomb which has capability
against subterranean facilities could in
iran you have the drawdown of troops in
iraq and afghanistan and i think an
eventual realization that sanctions are
not working and i just want to ask the
panel what they believe is the prognosis
down the road and view of these things
for military intervention in Iran all
right one hello my name is Mark Quran I
sort of subscribe to the doc
interpretation of international foreign
policy if it quacks like a duck looks
like a duck it should be a duck now
looking at the American us american
middle eastern policy right now what it
appears to me and this is in effect we
are over trying one by one all national
secular regimes in the Arab Middle East
and replacing them
with Muslim Brotherhood or derivative
regimes in the name of democracy freedom
and reform now I think this panel has to
treat seriously the question is this a
blunder a folly or an actual conscious
policy now having said that I want to go
back a little bit to the Turkish example
for which would which I'm specific you
know specially familiar now we're aware
of the agenda established by Graham
fuller professor fuller in the late 90s
and publicized by the RAND Corporation
regarding democratic Islam moderate
Islam and that Turkey would become an
example and a model for this and then
that would be applied to other countries
in the name of stability peace and so
forth the question here is
democratization really islamization are
we talking Orwellian here okay that's
that's that sort of coverage thank you
all right Pamela's please
I'll say a few words about Turkey which
has attracted much of my academic world
turkey is clearly deviating from nato
standard behavior and to give you just a
few examples it is only not two
countries that invited Ahmadinejad not a
turkey is only countries that invited
the butcher from her tomb to visit
Turkey it voted against the United
States at the United Nations Security
Council on on the Iranian sanction
resolution it is getting cozy with
putting actually put in and everyone our
world of the same feather it is siding
with Hamas not to the PA I can
understand I have a soft spot for
Palestinians but siding with Hamas is
weakening the PA is whickering abbas the
moderate its siding with hezbollah and
domestically what we see is that this
government actually allows erodes human
rights there is no longer an independent
judiciary and actually we see a lot of
concern among the liberal in Turkey
about the future of this country a
turkey is of course not a small
insignificant country turkey is almost
80 million people with an imperial
history in the Middle East and it's a
rising power actually the behavior of
Turkey is changing the balance of power
in the Middle East because it has
gravitated toward Iran I would suggest
to not thought to be very careful in
sharing sensitive information which
turkey because you cannot know if this
information will reach you learn
the Turks have also tried to impede the
NATO missile program in Eastern Europe
and in turkey so turkey is very bad news
and there is a window of opportunity in
June's have elections and I think
America in the West should make clear
that elder ones behavior and his
government is unacceptable in the West
because otherwise the message that goes
to the liberal circles in Turkey is that
America is supporting islamization of
Turkey this is how they are reading it
and they get desperate those elections
are crucial for the future of Turkey
about Iran an attack of Iran in my view
will on the nuclear installations would
need the instruction of a small amount
of ground troops in order to make sure
that what has to be destroyed is indeed
destroyed mm I think they it can be done
for Israel it's a bit more difficult
actually Austin Longo the famous article
about the ability of the Israeli Air
Force to get there in international
security and I'm sure we can get there
it's more difficult to come back hi I'd
like to address this to mr. Frisch and
mr. in bar when you were talking about
fear of Egypt being militarized by Iran
I was wondering if you were considering
three points first of all the Egyptian
military is not just a military in Egypt
it's a very big part of the Egyptian
government it owns mass
amounts of real estate besides other
things and it was considered a
moderating influence in the recent
uprising Secretary of State Clinton
praised the military's behavior and she
said that it was due mainly to the fact
that the US military trained them that's
my first point secondly about how do you
have a question uh in that new york
times article that you were reading i
read it also okay and what he said was
that many Egyptian political liberals
over all the years used to meet in the
coffee shops and talk politics and when
the authorities I need to hear a
question honey when I asked him if he
agrees with these points and when the
authority that's actually not a question
just needed to the question elements
found this out they closed up the coffee
shops and the Muslim Brotherhood was the
only group that lasted because they met
in the mosques and they couldn't close
the mosque my third point is professes
to boshy of Columbia University recently
wrote a book about the Shiites and he
said the Shiites are mainly a protest
movement and when they garner power it
usually fizzles out thank you
they there there wasn't a question so if
you want to address any of those points
I'll just talk about the Turkish the
Turkish found oil and Martin and
marketing about the Turkish model first
of all we don't know whether the Turkish
model is going to is really in the
direction of democracy or sir it's going
to Aslam Assize but many say that the
Egyptian Egyptians will follow the
Turkish model or the Indonesian model
which the American administration has
presumably studied there's a crucial
difference between the reality in Egypt
today and in Turkey in Turkey there were
two at least very highly
institutionalized parties and remains to
this day the Republican Party and the
Nationalist Party which has existed
since 1969 in its present form and which
dates back to the 1940s even older these
are two institutionalized parties that
can always be some kind of counterweight
to islamization in Egypt there is no
institutional counterweight to the
Muslim Brotherhood there's nothing
there's nothing unless unless Mubarak's
former party the National Democratic
Party will resurrect itself under
another name and that's very good that's
very questionable about the military
being being moderate certainly the
military is more moderate the military
remembers what happened to the Iranian
military in the Iranian Revolution where
it where the people many of the generals
were slaughtered and killed and those
who and those who escaped that kind of
fate were sent to the battlefields with
unprepared troops against against Iraq
so they certainly will try we'll try on
avoiding a Muslim Brotherhood a Muslim
Brotherhood
outcome but as I said revolutionary
situations are usually disastrous
sequels the meanest and the most
organized take over then there's civil
war and then there's foreign
intervention I think the military which
is pretty weak pretty weak will be
strong enough to create a civil war but
will not be strong enough to prevent a
Muslim takeover simply because they will
be elections there is going to be
elections and the military can't run as
a political party I'll just say this on
the notion which is pretty common that
somehow contact with the US military
pacifies or makes more respectful of
human rights or whatever I think this is
at best an untested hypothesis and it
worse de canard I have a lot of friends
that teach at us professional military
institutions they have students who come
from many of the military's we're
talking about not just Egypt I don't get
the sense from them and I don't get the
sense from interacting with some of
these students that it's much more than
a chance to hang out in the US for a
year I don't I don't feel that they
imbibe in some deep meaningful way u.s.
values I mean it takes a long time to
inculcate values in US personnel often
starting at a very young age coming to a
war college or Special Forces school or
whatever for a year or six weeks or
whatever is not really going to cut it
so I wouldn't I wouldn't believe the
hype on that one Oh could I just add one
point since I did right maybe the only
article ever on the relationship between
religion and Arab armies are used the
official journals the official army
journals of each respective state Egypt
Syria and Jordan the Egyptian army is
deeply religious this is how even how
the official state wanted to represent
it one of the chief incentives to get
people to join is that if you become an
NCO you sub your Hajj
is subsidized in other words in other
words when I compared the Egyptian army
for instance to the Syrian army the
Egyptian army is truly religious and I
think this is one of the problems the
officer class doesn't trust the
rank-and-file I think the rank and file
is probably very religious and some of
them very Pro Muslim Brotherhood which
is one of the reasons why the military's
trunk has been trying to appease the
Muslim Brotherhood they took a man by
the name of Terra kalbi suree Muslim
Brotherhood constitutionalists to head
the committee for the amendments of the
Constitution and was upon which there
was a referendum and the Coptics and
other liberals were furious with this
appointment I I was just wondering if
Western intervention in Egypt whether
indirectly through the attempts to unite
these little parties or directly if it
comes to it through a naval blockade or
sending in ground troops if that could
be viewed by Arabs in the region as
another example of the West attempting
to deter self-determination in the
region in the same vein of as us support
for the regime in Egypt the ca sponsored
Iranian kuz British installation of Amir
fazal as puppet monarch in Iraq and
French suppression of Syrian revolts and
whether if if that is the case if that
could serve to radicalize the response
in the region but from actors such as
Muslim Brotherhood towards the west
we'll take another hi my name is Martin
willner I want to ask a question about
the u.s. arms export economy and its
role in the Middle East policy based on
the recent level of uncertainty there
what do you see the future us arms
export economy to look like and in
particular do you see any arms sales
increasing to any countries in the
region based on the levels of
uncertainty well armed sales I don't
worry about that very much I think we
can probably survive with the with our
economy it just relied on on the sale of
arms and believe me uncertainty does
breed arm sales and so I will not be at
all surprised if we have big arms sales
contracts with Iraq as it begins to go
they don't have an Air Force well we'll
sell them an Air Force you know there's
a lot of places where that can wear that
can go so I you know I don't see this as
I see nothing on the horizon that
suggests that that part of the economy
is going to suffer because of the
uncertainty in the Middle East and as I
say I'm not sure that that matters very
much in terms of where either the Middle
East or the u.s. goes let me make one
statement make one point with regard to
the really the very great sense of
urgency that I hear from both the panel
and from people elsewhere about you know
the Iranian nuclear program there was I
recall a speech made by someone you may
have heard of named Netanyahu in making
the statement that if the United States
doesn't intervene Iran is going to have
a nuclear weapon in three to five years
that statement was made to the Knesset
in 1992 and ever since that time and not
just because he said it
the threat of a nuclear weapon in Iran's
hands has been three to five years away
and it is still that is the latest US
military that's the latest US
intelligence no estimate that Iran is
three to five years away from a nuclear
weapon my question really is if Iran so
desperately needs and wants a nuclear
weapon what has been holding them back
that's a long time it's almost 20 years
and you know in that process they now
have more low-enriched uranium than they
had before very true they've probably
done some tabletop experiments we caught
them at it basically figuring out how
you would build a weapon that would fit
on a missile but they don't have a
weapon and you know the idea that
somehow the only way one can deal with
this desperate urgent threat is for the
United States not anybody else for the
United States to go in bomb them and
then of course put some boots on the
ground because you've got to determine
what actually happened with the bombing
raids and that's the only way you can
determine it that is you know there are
there are American generals who are
proposing this solution I don't find any
American politicians supporting this and
I think that they're not going to and
basically if I were running on a
platform if anybody was running on a
platform in this country in which that
was their basic plank about their policy
in the Middle East we're going to get
tough we're going to throw our weight
around we're going to show them who's
boss and we're going to bomb Iran and
put boots on the ground there I would
not give that person a very strong
chance of becoming president now we can
talk all we like about our
interpretation of what needs to be done
but I've been struck by the fact that
it's all about how the US is supposed to
do these things
and we're being and you know given a lot
of suggestions about what we ought to do
um you know I I wonder about that and I
wonder whether in fact this is going to
make any is going to in fact affect us
strategy in any significant way and I I
think we really have to keep that in
mind both the urgency of the thing and
the fact of what really the political
realities are I'll just I'll just
respond to the idea of intervention of
American intervention in Egypt and maybe
what that could arouse now it's it's
simple I wonder thought an organ an Arab
press organ of the Iranians called
alwafaq and in Al we FAC they made the
point that they are going to support the
demonstrators the revolutionaries who
call them what you want of course not
the Democrats that's the one word they
didn't use in Egypt now this is the same
Iranian regime this is a regime organ
that suppress the Democrats just 10
months ago so when they say they will
support the egyptian demonstrators who
are they referring to of course they're
referring to the muslim brotherhood and
it's it's clear to egyptian zaz well
that since Iranians are going to be
supporting the muslim brotherhood and
they're going to be pumping a lot of
money into the coming elections most
Egyptians on the posts expect that the
United States and the European community
will be involved in propping up the
other side and this is what's going to
an in the potential civil war after the
elections that's probably how it's going
to
all the Iranians will support the Muslim
Brotherhood as they support Hamas in in
Hamas Stan in in Gaza and the Americans
are European community are going to
support the opposing side let me remind
you that the Americans there were
American forces in the Bolshevik
Revolution who supported the White
Russians I don't think there is great
difference between the assessment of the
Israeli intelligence and the Merrick
intelligence about the progress of of
the nuclear program I think they may
differ a year or two which you know any
story tells when it doesn't mean much
and so the sense of urgency is indeed
much greater in in our part of the world
and it's not only Jerusalem it's also in
Riyadh and in Cairo which to you are
agree with you that the molecules don't
seem to share it hey I must say that
argument about you know what is
electable here as a measure for good
policy in the Middle East is not very
convincing once you voted good president
good question you know I'm a great
believer in democracy but democracies
can make mistakes and I think that
America made once in a while mistakes
despite being the greatest democracy in
the world so you know its a restart
eject judgment and political outcomes
I'm talking about strategic realities
rather than what is electable here or
politically wise to propose to the to
the American people we definitely see a
strategic fatigue on part of the United
States about you know giving you advice
I think that Israel has been very good
at doing the dirty job for Americans on
several occasions just to remind you you
know the Syrian reactor you know
Iraqi reactor I don't think that if we
develop this to happen it would have
been a good outcome so sometimes
Americans for some reason don't want to
do it then we have no choice but to do
it by the way I think that the moment of
decision in Israel is getting closer
precisely because you know it's not five
years ago as two years now i agree that
it takes some ? on you know and the
intelligence services and you know
intelligence surfaces always do not
always know everything but they they are
advancing that's quite clear and I think
that the nonchalant attitude toward a
nuclear Iran is very problematic to put
it at least about Western intervention
Western intervention cannot do the trick
in the Middle East only domestic
developments there are certain things
that you can prevent by intervention
basically trying to limit capabilities
to harm you this is a policy i had okay
to my government you know you should try
to do only a very modest policy try to
limit the capabilities of your enemies
to harm you i think a nuclear Iran can
harm the letter states as well and i
hope the Americans will understand I
think that's it
you